get out
ma'am get out of the car come on take a
seat belt I'll take your seatbelt off
there's a car in there
get out
take your seatbelt off and get out of
the car
shake your seasoning off come on it's
made up take your seat back
can you give us an exact address
come on
get out of the car come on
hey is there anybody else in the car is
there anybody else in the car
[Music]
is there anybody else in the car
is there anybody in the car
where
is there somebody in the car who
bam
we're in the back seat or the front
hey is there anybody in the car
s
over there
incredible
yes send EMS and fire 10 18.
Square Fire EMS
there's nobody else in the car
will you help me tow her away from this
car come on